when one of your best slit sequences in
the entire episode is the opening
credits that's not great giving your
main characters the glory of being on
the front line when we all know there
isn't a chance in hell that any of them
are dying in the initial onslaught i'd
have given back all the sins of [ __ ]
sam was taken out by a stray arrow in
the first few minutes then i'd have
spent the episode caring about who was
going to survive instead of [ __ ]
around with my contrast settings oh for
[ __ ] sake
took your time
attempting to conceal your your late sin
behind a you took your time greeting now
you have two sins man they've got a
nice-sized army here ready and willing
to fight the dead but it still makes no
sense that the uss enterprise isn't here
to help the fight just in case i never
get a chance to sin favor the bold from
season six of star trek deep space nine
this seemed like as good a place as any
to do it i'm actually glad wolfie the
white is here finally gives me someone
to root for not because i'm particularly
attached to him but because he's the
only damn character i'm gonna be able to
see and if you like this shot you're
going to love the rest of the episode
okay if you haven't guessed it already
this sends video will have a theme just
wanted to let you know rather than you
know keeping you in the dark i find it
very strange that jon isn't on the front
line with his people like he was for the
battle of the bastards or basically
every single time there's any fighting
at all i know he's the only other person
that knows how to fly a dragon but do
they really need a pilot can danny not
just tell them to do what dragons do in
the general direction of the bad guys
sir davos is acting as if he knows the
figure in the distance is melisandre and
that is some retina defying superhuman
visioning levels of total bullsh
maybe if it was daylight the distinctive
red hair would be a giveaway but she's
wearing a [ __ ] hood oh [ __ ] you
i'm glad all the dothraki heard jorah
the back row could have very easily been
a dothraki kebab seems like melisandre
should have given at least a heads up as
to what she was going to do also why are
the dothraki the only ones that get the
eternal flame advantage if you're going
to bring spells to class melisandre you
need to bring enough for everyone also
also this is a cool visual but
everyone's acting as if melisandre just
turned these things into [ __ ]
lightsabers when they're just on fire if
this is really gonna make a difference
why didn't they do it themselves it's
exactly what they do with arrows so stop
[ __ ] about and get those shafts oiled
wait there's no need to execute me sir
devos i'll be dead before the dawn this
works this episode has so many long
stairs that i can only assume the set
was as poorly lit as the show itself and
that this is just everyone's way of
making sure that their eyes have
adjusted before accidentally delivering
their lines to a wall so part of the
battle plan was just to have jorah and
the dothraki blindly charge the army of
the dead they have the likes of daenerys
jorah greyworm sir davos tyrion john and
jaime planning this and this was the
best they could come up with this will
be a long night indeed but mostly for
the audience
okay this is a pretty badass shot and
since i probably won't be able to see
the rest of the episode well enough to
remove any more sins i guess we'll take
it off here however if your big set
piece is so dark that you have to rely
on flaming swords to allow us to see
what the hell is going on i think you
may be taking the realism thing a touch
too seriously especially when that
realism doesn't extend to a very angry
ice smurf raising an army of zombies on
the back of a dragon wouldn't it have
been a good idea to launch these badass
siege weapons before you send in your
first wave of dothraki to the slaughter
i can see waiting until you know the
enemies within range but they fire them
before the dothraki even make contact so
what do they know now that they didn't
know a few minutes ago i mean why should
they show the battle between the
dothraki and the storming dead when we
can just see everyone else's expression
as they try to ascertain how the battle
is going that was a much better idea
the night king is coming
the dead are already here what the [ __ ]
is danny doing did she seriously expect
the night king to fly in first and
politely present himself for inspection
before sending in his minions the plan
was to stay back protect bran and lure
in the night king nothing that's
happened in the first five minutes of
this battle is surprising enough to
warrant immediately abandoning that plan
earlier somebody shouted
presumably to make sure they don't wipe
out their own people but since that
battle is clearly done why didn't they
reload and start firing again also why
are these incredibly long range siege
weapons positioned on what has very
quickly become the front line do they
never get used again why wouldn't you
use these again if you like us have been
waiting eight years for this epic fight
between the undead the unsullied the
wildlings and all the other assorted
humans then here's a tip how to enjoy it
best close all the curtains [ __ ] around
with the brightness on your tv and then
take your remote throw it through the
damn screen of frustration and then just
imagine something better in your head
i don't know how to use it
sticking with the pointy end we got
callbacks y'all i mean no offense to
samuel's fighting abilities
well actually i mean all of the offense
because i find it ridiculous that he
survived this long in close contact
combat
get up friend saves friend in combat
only to then get killed themselves
immediately afterward cliche also one of
the unique things about the early
seasons of game of thrones was that you
truly felt no one was safe and anyone
could die at any point the problem with
killing poor ed here is that yes it
could randomly happen but he's just
lovable enough to make me sad and not
important enough to make me care so now
i'm just sad and left wondering why ed
why ed
now in fairness i've never flown a
dragon but they're capable of flying
straight up yes i just feel like rising
above the storm would be a better option
than blindly flying around inside of it
john actually believes that dany would
be able to hear him what is this a
battlefield for ants
light the trench light the threat are we
supposed to believe the davos can hear
grey worm why does no one in this
episode seem to grasp the concept of how
sound travels oh good glad we're getting
more of the how to train your dragon in
the fog scenes this episode is 80
minutes and this episode did not need to
be 80 minutes she can't see us welcome
to the party pal if melisandre can
conjure up enough fire to fill up an
entire trench there are clearly some
skills of hers they're not putting to
use against the army of the dead ice
people meanwhile on tales from the crypt
at least we're already in a crypt
[Laughter]
i'm laughing but holy [ __ ] dude they're
children and terrified civilians down
here then probably aren't as accepting
of your dark humor as the audience at
home is if we're up there
we might see something everyone else is
missing i can say with confidence you
would not maybe we should have stayed
married and maybe we should just go
ahead and skip the things i did
everything you did brought you where you
are now home never mind about betraying
rob stealing winterfell killing sir
roderick abandoning sansa and his actual
sister yara oh and those two kids he
executed because he thought they were
his adopted brothers hall is forgiven
because he came home
great you've got the white walkers
stalled as the trenches burning this
might be a great time to start shooting
arrows and killing as many as you can oh
just gonna wait until they form a plan
to get past the burning trench great
call also the fire mode is pretty badass
but did no one see this tactic coming i
mean this thing is what 10 feet wide
dead overcame in a matter of minutes how
was this ever a viable defense game of
the world wars the army of darkness
lord barrack here knows damn well that
clegane has a pretty severe version of
flamey things so perhaps beckoning him
with a very sharp flamey thing isn't the
best way of getting him back in the game
okay if they're going to show one piece
of combat clearly i'm glad it was arya
kicking all of the undead ass she
[ __ ] rules but this does prove that
somebody putting this [ __ ] together
knows how to shoot action and i wish
they'd been given a bigger say in how to
put this episode together rather than
whoever thought it would be better to
make us really feel what it's like to
fight our way out of a slightly amber
paper bag
looks like lady mormont went to the
rickenstark school of not getting the
[ __ ] out of the way of a stampeding
giant so not only did the winterfell
gang not lead the fight with the dragons
their best option the zombies decided to
wait to bring in the [ __ ] zombie
giant neither of these parties deserves
a win today
man this is [ __ ] up even for game of
thrones and fortunately this mindless
giant will play with its food long
enough and at eye level enough for lady
mormont to stab it in the brain look i
know this is supposed to be an epic
moment but it's hard to get excited when
it feels more staged than aoen facing
down sauron
i suppose now is a good time as any to
ask how exactly does the dragon breath
work and how long does it last i mean
the dead dragon seems to be able to
sustain this indefinitely so why would
it stop before finishing the job and why
don't we see more of daenerys and john
lighting up the army of the dead now
that they're committed to the brand
he'll be fine plan the point is i don't
know whether i'm supposed to be worried
for the good guys facing this
unstoppable force or pissed off at them
for not using their own
so they have super hearing sensitive
enough to hear a drop of blood across
the room since when was that a [ __ ]
thing arya gets out from under the table
and behind another bookcase in the
second and a half it takes this zombie
to bend down and look for her arya's
pretty badass but she's not the [ __ ]
flash [ __ ] hell arya did she just
walk around corners with her blade up at
all times what if that had been theon or
jorah wait can we actually make this
theon or jorah instead i get the
instinct to act fast but why would you
throw away your awesome sword imbued
with power by an actual god knowing
there's a good chance you won't be able
to get that [ __ ] back this is like
obi-wan throwing his [ __ ] lightsaber
at a group of stormtroopers without the
ability to force pull it back the
youtube gods forbid us from playing the
music but the opening chords of this
part of the score sound straight up like
the opening of instincts bye bye bye and
it ain't no lie that i'd give back all
the sins if we got a battle montage with
these sweet sweet vocal tones of one mr
justin timberlake and one mr jc chazy
backing it up i know you no i know you
well that's exciting and useful
information for this episode to be
taking its time with presenting 80
minutes long just thought i'd mention
that again
what do we say to the god of death
not today we got even more callbacks
y'all how is either writer staying on
their dragon when they're in this
position and for anyone who says they're
holding on tight i hate you
jorah translates drogon's roar perfectly
into hey daenerys is going to be in some
big trouble we need you to ex machina
meet us there and tan drakaris cool but
weren't john and daenerys armed with any
dragonglass the one thing known to be
effective against the white walkers no
one anticipated the supernatural
creature able to raise the dead would
attempt to raise the dead might have
been tricky in the heat of battle but
wouldn't stabbing your own dead with
dragonglass just to be safe be better
than having to face them all over again
earlier tyrion protested that his brain
was being wasted down here yet neither
he nor anybody else seem to note the
inherent flaw in hiding in a crypt
filled with dead bodies while being
invaded by a creature whose ability to
raise the dead features pretty
prominently on their resume the dead
have been attacking in hordes this
entire episode but are now running in
one at a time so theon and his merry men
can easily pick them off with their
flaming arrows dragon x machina but to
be fair there should have been a hell of
a lot more of these throughout the
episode so am i also sending there
weren't enough dragon ex machinas yes
yes i am hey you know those big flappy
appendages on the side of your giant
lizard yeah those aren't just fancy
umbrellas when flapped they negate the
need to be on the damn ground which is
the only place any of these guys can
even remotely cause you a problem during
this sequence we essentially see every
single main character get overwhelmed by
undead cannon fodder and yet jorah is
the only one who dies not saying i
wanted them all dead just don't expect
to feel any kind of tension or suspense
when what you're showing me has no
impact on the end result i realize the
fire is blue so we know it's the night
king's dragon but that doesn't make blue
dragon flames any less of a sin you're a
good man now go and run head first into
the night king instead of attempting to
buy any more time
i'm honestly not sure if they're about
to fight or [ __ ] and i'm also not sure
which i'd rather see i mean it can't be
any weirder than theon trying to [ __ ]
your sister
shouting at a dragon seriously though
what exactly was john's game plan here
is this literally giving up and offering
your body up to be barbecued that means
no helping brand no saving winterfell
and no more westeros fortunately arya
has a bit more sense but he doesn't know
that after all he's been through this is
where he throws in the towel
[Music]
okay that was [ __ ] cool sure is handy
that every single one of these creatures
is linked to the night king i mean this
was a huge [ __ ] gamble and they'd
have been completely screwed otherwise
also it looks like the white walker army
went to the blip school of dying very
gradually instead of all at once the tv
since university should really think
about getting a bigger campus i guess i
won't be needing this anymore
what's going on who turned off the
lights
well it's a very attractive proposition
gentlemen but unfortunately not
practical you see my medium is light
it'll be pitch dark i won't be able to
see a thing i don't know but i've been
told i don't know but i've been slow
eskimo she has mighty cold basketball
she is mighty cold
head up
get me down from here
at least we're already in a crib at no
point in your rambling incoherent
response were you even close to anything
that could be considered a rational
thought everyone in this room is now
dumber for having listened to it
you might be surprised at the lengths
i'd go to avoid joining the army of the
dead i could think of no organization
less suited to my talents the ability to
speak does not make you intelligent
hey lord of the flame
your tail's on fire
i'm not dead
incoming